["Moi j'ai travaillé une vingtaine d'années au ministère de la défense français sur différents domaines...
A quel poste?
Tout sauf de l'administration, c'est-à-dire affaires stratégiques, exportation d'armement, reseignement et d'une manière générale, réflexion sur l'organisation du ministère.
Poste que j'ai quitté au début des années 2000 pour diriger une société d'intelligence économique pendant environ 8 ans.
Maintenant ça va, je suis retraité, heureux parce que je peux faire ce que j'ai envie de faire c'est à dire en fait écrire, je suis libéré de la parole..."]
Bonjour Pierre Conesa !
Bonjour.
Nous vous interviewons aujourd'hui pour une chaîne YouTube qui s'appelle Thinkerview.
On aurait voulu discuter un peu de l'Arabie Saoudite. Qu'est-ce que vous pouvez-vous nous en dire à l'heure actuelle, au vu de l'actualité, des câbles Wikileaks, qu'est-ce que vous en pensez?
L'Arabie Saoudite est un pays absolument magnifique, c'est une espèce de Disneyland de l'Islam c'est à dire que tout est faux,
C'est-à-dire vous avez des gens qui croient qu'ils pratiquent une religion et qui ne la pratiquent pas. Ils arrivent à tout interdire,
c'est-à-dire il n'y a pas de cinéma, de bibliothèque, il n'y a pas de théâtre il n'y a rien du tout puisque tout ça évidemment détourne de la religion
mais paradoxalement quand les saoudiens sont à l'étranger, tout à coup ils deviennent de véritables voyous, ils se payent des prostituées, ils boivent de l'alcool, etc...
Puis ensuite quand ils rentrent au pays ils font de gros dons à des organisations humanitaires qui vont en général financer Daech donc voilà, c'est un pays assez étonnant dans sa structure sociale.
Après, Wikileaks? Les câbles Wikileaks?
C'est à dire que les câbles Wikileaks n'ont fait que révéler une chose que l'on subodorait enfin dont ont pensait qu'elle était assez systématique mais on n'en avait pas de preuve bien évidente...
C'est-à-dire que l'Arabie Saoudite est un pays magique puisque finalement le niveau de vie par tête doit être probablement le plus élevé de la planète
mais essentiellement puisque c'est un énorme producteur de pétrole.
Et donc qu'il y ait une diplomatie du carnet de chèques pour acheter des élites dans un certain nombre de pays n'est pas en soi très étonnant
cela dit ont peut faire du carnet de chèques direct ou on peut faire des intérêts communs, genre la famille Bush avec la famille Ben Laden par exemple.
Donc encore une fois, Wikileaks a révélé des choses qu'on subodorait mais en apportant des peuves précises, au Maroc, au Liban, etc...
Est-ce que vous pouvez développer un peu la position avec Ben Laden, la famille Ben Laden et la famille Bush?
Non, la famille Ben Laden n'est pas en soin un sujet d'intérêt parce que d'abord, c'est une énorme famille donc qu'il y ait dedans des gens qui soient proches de Mohammed le terroriste
ou qu'il y ait des gens qui s'appellent aussi Mohammed Ben Laden et qui n'ont rien à voir avec lui, c'est une réalité,
il y a un avocat, d'ailleurs francophone qui porte exactement le même nom et qui en fait est un avocat d'affaires parfaitement respectable.
Donc la famille Ben Laden, ça n'est pas une totalité, c'est une entité hétérogène, celui qui nous intéresse évidemment, c'est celui qui a été emporté à notre affection il y a quelques années.
Donc ce qui est intéressant n'est pas le fait que la famille Ben Laden, c'est surtout le fait que, quand on a eu les attentats du 11 Septembre,
on sait bien que le gouvernement américain a autorisé ce qui vivait de famille Ben Laden aux Etats-Unis à s'en aller discrètement.
Mais le tour de passe-passe le plus prodigieux de l'Arabie Saoudite, c'est quand même le fait que quand le 11 Septembre...
Alors je vous coupe... Ce tour de passe-passe, l'exfiltration de la famille Ben Laden, quand l'espace aérien américain était fermé, c'est ça?
Oui c'est ça, exacement. Non le tour de passe-passe le plus étonnant et qui finalement est magnifique dans sa réalisation, c'est le fait qu'il y a 11 saoudiens sur 19 terroristes dans les attentats du 11 Septembre
et que 2 mois plus tard, George Bush énnonce que les pays de l'axe du mal, c'est l'Irak, l'Iran et la Corée du Nord et il évite soigneursement l'Arabie Saoudite.
Donc ça c'est un tour de passe-passe stratégique auquel je regrette que les européens se soient prêtés en silence.
Puisque quand-même, c'était une évidence que ce pays était déjà vérolé par le terrorisme à cause de sa pratique de l'Islam
et que arriver à l'éviter pour ne pas toucher à des intérêts économiques, commerciaux, pétroliers, etc... Etait quand-même une escroquerie intellectuelle et stratégique
encore une fois à laquelle des gouvernants de l'époque... Enfin on était dans les mois du 11 Septembre donc c'était difficile de critiquer le gouvernenement américain.
Le résultat on l'a vu, c'est qu'il y a eu l'invasion de l'Irak dont les conséquences continuent encore aujoud'hui.
Vous parliez de la diplomatie du carnet de chèques. Est-ce qu'on voit un peu la diplomatie religieuse du carnet de chèques par chez nous, dans le monde entier, qu'est-ce qu'il se passe?
Oui, l'autre aspect qui me parait très intéressant c'est la diplomatie religieuse de l'Arabie Saoudite, parce que la diplomatie du carnet de chèques, à la limite c'est de la diplomatie classique,
c'est ce que faisait Mobutu aussi pour rester au pouvoir c'est-à-dire qu'il payait à droite et à gauche pour pouvoir être sûr que les élections ne perturbent pas sa dictature.
Non, ce qui est le plus intéressant c'est qu'à partir de 1973, l'Arabie Saoudite, à cause du boum des prix du pétrole, va toucher en 3 jours ce qu'elle touchait en 1 an.
Et se trouve donc à la tête d'une masse financière gigantesque et pour bien comprendre le régime saoudien, il faut savoir que c'est un régime politico-religieux,
c'est-à-dire que c'est l'alliance des wahhabites, enfin des disciples d'Abdel Wahhab et de la famille d'Ibn Saoud qui vont faire ce régime saoudien.
Et donc, à la tête de cette fortune immense qui explose à partir de 1973, se développe une diplomatie religieuse qui, dans le cadre de l'Islam,
va essentiellement consister à développer la pratique saoudienne de l'Islam.
La plus rigoriste?
Oui la plus rigoriste, c'est-à-dire celle qui coupe les mains des voleurs, qui décapite, qui opprime les femmes et qui interdisent les autres religions.
Donc ces critères-là, ils faut les retenir parce qu'on va les retrouver ailleurs.
Et donc, extraordinairement, quand les disciples d'Abdel Wahhab arrivent et prennent la Mecque en même temps qu'Ibn Saoud,
ils détruisent le cimetière dans lequel sont enterrés les compagnons du prophète, c'est pour dire que ce sont des rigoristes au sens où il n'y a que l'adoration de dieu.
Même les compagnons du prophète , leur tombe sont considérées comme impies parce que ça pourrait développer un culte des saints.
Donc ce grand humanisme qu'est la pratique saoudienne de l'Islam va être diffusé un peu partout sur la planète avec des moyens financiers gigantesques.
C'est-à-dire que l'on crée des madrasas donc des écoles coraniques, on distribue des bourses, on distribue des bouquins,
on distribue des bourses pour des étudiants qui veulent venir en Arabie Saoudite apprendre le coran,
On donne évidemment très largement la traduction saoudienne du coran qui n'est pas tout à fait la même que d'autres traductions,
et donc, autour de ces foyers dans des pays, cette stratégie est planétaire. C'est ça qui est très étonnant, c'est-à-dire que ça vient évidememnt ici,
on a eu pas mal d'imams saoudiens qui nous ont été fournis en même temps que la contruction de mosquées, par contre,
ce qu'on a pas eu raison de regarder c'est ce qui se passait ailleurs : en Afrique sub-saharienne où l'on a vu par exemple au Mali qu'il y avait des salafistes et on a été surpris qu'il y en ait.
On en a vu en République Centrafricaine, on en voit au Nigeria, etc...
Et donc cette stratégie était planétaire mais on ne l'a pas surveillée parce que notre réseau diplomatique n'a pas vocation à surveiller les évolution des cultes musulmans dans les pays où il est installé.
Que faisait la DGSE?
Mais la DGSE ne s'occupait pas de ça, c'est-à-dire qu'à partir de 1979, la donne stratégique est complètement transformée
et surtout l'Arabie Saoudite devient un allié essentiel pour deux raisons : d'abord parce que début 1979, il y a la révolution iranienne.
La révolution iranienne, c'est une révolution démocratique, ça personne n'en doute si vous voulez, ensuite on pense ce que l'on veut du régime mais en tout cas les gens étaient dans la rue.
Et les saoudiens sont tétanisés à l'idée qu'il puisse y avoir un régime politique chiite non-arabe qui s'installe à leur porte et qui puisse prétendre prendre le leadership sur la communauté musulmane.
Donc ça c'est un choc terrible mais ils ont une opportunité formidable qui est le fait que fin 1979, la même année, les soviétiques envahissent l'Afghanistan.
Et donc à ce moment-là, ils vont prendre la tête du Jihad, c'est à ce moment-là que ressort le terme, pour aller combattre les mécréants c'est-à-dire les soviétiques,
qui pour eux sont dans ma même catégorie que les occidentaux, ils y en a qui sont bons, il y en a qui sont les méchants mais tous sont des mécréants.
Et donc il va y avoir le soutien aux afghans résistants à l'Union Soviétique et une grande participation de beaucoup de saoudiens d'ailleurs à cette guerre.
On pense qu'à peu près 70% des combattants étrangers à l'époque viennent d'Arabie Saoudite. Alors se passe à ce moment là un processus là aussi que l'on n'a pas vu arriver,
c'est que parmi les conditions mises par le prince Turki, le chef des services de renseignement par lequel transitait l'aide pour les afghans,
il va imposer au régime du maréchal Zia, qui est un régime islamiste amateur par rapport au saoudien ; il va lui imposer l'ouverture de madrassas donc d'écoles coraniques version Wahabbite.
Et puis avec tout ce qui va avec : les bourses, les bouquins, les bibliothèques, les machins, etc... Et le produit final que l'on va voir sortir, c'est les talibans.
Puisque "Talibans", étymologiquement, c'est les étudiants en religion. C'est-à-dire ces gens qui vont tout à coup raser tout ce qu'ils trouvent sur leur passage,
qui vont déjà mettre en oeuvre ce que l'on retrouve aujourd'hui à Daech ou ce qui est régulèrement pratiqué en Arabie Saoudite,
c'est-à-dire la lapidation des femmes, la décapitation etc... Pour les homosexuels, ils ont fait preuve d'inventivité
puisqu'ils estimaient que les homosexuels, il fallait qu'un bulldozer écrase un mur sur eux, donc ils étaient quand-même assez novateurs, les talibans dans la répression.
Donc, simultanément, autre épisode aussi en Algérie, vous avez 10 années de guerre civile où vous avez des salafistes, les Groupes Islamiques Armées "GIA"
puis ensuite le "GSPC" : Groupe Salafiste pour la Prédication et le Combat qui vont massacrer d'autres musulmans,
en Algérie ça a fait quand même 100 000 à 150 000 morts on sait pas très bien. Mais encore une fois, tout ça ce sont des conséquences indirectes de ce Jihad
qui au départ était tourné contre les mécréants et qui progressivement va se tourner contre les régimes arabes mécréants, c'est-à-dire les régimes de mauvais musulmans.
Mauvais musulmans parce-que... peut-être à la botte des pays occidentaux ou instrumentalisés par les pays occidentaux, ou jugés comme tel?
C'est un mélange de plusieurs choses, c'est-à-dire que les salafistes considèrent d'abord que le principe constitutionnel, qu'il soit dictatorial ou démocratique,
de toutes façons, prétendrait rendre supérieure la loi des hommes à la loi de dieu donc il n'y a pas besoin de constitution dans un régime salafiste, du moment qu'on applique la Charia
et qu'on suit le coran, qu'on va chercher toutes les questions dans le coran, à ce moment-là il n'y a même pas besoin de savoir si le régime est mécréant ou pas puisque le régime ne doit pas exister.
Et donc qu'ils soient alliés des occidentaux ou qu'ils ne le soient pas, c'est-à-dire ils vont se battre contre le père Assad par exemple, avec une insurrection, les frères musulmans en particulier,
mais qui va être réprimée dans le sang par le père Assad dans la ville de Hama. Mais ils vont se battre de la même façon contre le régime algérien qui se prétend successeur de la guerre d'idépendance, etc...
Donc encore une fois, ce n'est pas la base -alliance occidentale- ou pas, c'est la contestation de leur légitimité comme gouvernant.
Et donc encore une fois, tout doit être dicté par le coran, par exemple, épisode rigolo, quand il y a eu l'affaire Cliton - Monika Lewinsky par exemple,
qu'il s'était fait faire une fellation par une stagiaire, il y a eu un débat sur Al-Jazeera qui est une télé Qatarie, sur le thème "Est-ce que la fellation est hallal ou pas?"
Avec des docteurs en théologie qui venaient donner leur avis. Notamment pendant la période du ramadan, ça posait une question importante puisque vous voyez le problème technique que ça pose...
Et donc c'est ce genre de chose, c'est-à-dire l'idée que l'on a dans une lecture littérale du coran, réponse à tout. Même peut-être sur internet, ils vont y trouver demain des réponses aussi.
Donc encore une fois, c'est cette pratique-là, c'est-à-dire la plus obscurantiste et cette diplomatie religieuse, en 35 ans,
c'est à peu-près 1500 mosquées qui sont ouvertes avec des fonds saoudiens... 1500 mosquées ça commence à faire pas mal.
1500 mosquées en France? Ou...
Non non, sur l'ensemble de la planète, puisque cette action est quand-même un peu partout sur la planète encore une fois, beaucoup en Afrique, en Asie beaucoup,
aussi pas mal en Russie à partir de 1991, il y a même aujourd'hui des islamistes au Tatarstan, il en a évidemment au Caucase, etc...
Donc c'est cette vision planétaire qu'on a eu beaucoup de mal à surveiller puisque finalement, chacun de ces postes n'avait pas à ce demander ce que faisait l'Arabie Saoudite.
Il y aurait fallu une impulsion politique en disant "mais qu'est-ce que fait l'Arabie Saoudite dans ces différents endroits?"
Et là on entre dans un débat qui est beaucoup plus général, c'est-à-dire comment les occidentaux se sont-ils comportés vis-à-vis de ce régime?
Alors par exemple, Richard Baer [Robert Baer?], un des patrons du renseignement américain, racontait que pendant longtemps,
il était interdit de faire du renseignement sur l'Arabie Saoudite. Interdit.
C'est interdit sur l'Arabie Saoudite, mais en France, on peut?
Ah oui oui, bien sûr mais encore une fois, le véto était venu pour des raisons politiques, pas pour des raisons stratégiques, c'est-à-dire
qu'ils avaient peur d'un incident diplomatique, qu'un type se fasse prendre et à partir de ce moment là, toute sanction commerciale, tout ce que l'on pet imaginer mais
je veux dire, la lâcheté stratégique que ça représente est assez gigantesque.
Je ne sais pas ce qu'il en était pour les français mais en tout cas pour les américains on a eu confirmation que c'était interdit.
Vous parlez de lâcheté, à l'heure actuelle est-ce que vous pensez que le position du gouvernement français vis-à-vis de l'Arabie Saoudite est une position de "lâche"?
C'est-à-dire qu'on se trouve dans cette situation étonnante où on est est en train de faire la guerre à Daech pour des raisons qui sont assez évidentes...
On a décapité des types, on coupe les mains des voleurs, on opprime les femmes, on interdit les autres religions donc il vous manque une casse, il faut la remplir.
Parce qu'en fait, vous parlez de l'Arabie Saoudite, que vous parliez de Daech ou de l'Arabie Saoudite, c'est pareil.
Et donc on en arrive à se battre contre Daech d'une manière qui d'ailleurs dans sa motivation est assez scandaleuse,
quand vous avez des sites de jeunes islamistes en France et qui vous disent 1200 morts à Gaza on fait rien, 4 occidentaux égorgés on envoie l'armée...
On peut comprendre qu'ils soient scandalisés par une diplomatie de double standard comme ça.
Bref, on se retrouve à se battre aux côtés des américains contre Daech, régime pour lequel on peut n'avoir aucune sympathie...
Mais pour défendre celui qui y a donné naissance, c'est-à-dire l'Arabie Saoudite, ça fait un peu comme dans le roman de Mary Shelley,
c'est-à-dire que le docteur Frankenstein voudrait bien qu'on le débarrasse de son monstre, mais dans le roman, il disparait en même temps que lui,
tandis que nous, on voudrait que le monstre disparaisse mais pas le géniteur. Donc ça a un côté un peu cocasse.
Un exemple si vous voulez, quand on regarde la structure des forces qui bombardent Daech aujourd'hui, les Saoudiens ont 2 fois moins d'avions que les français.
Par contre, ils en ont 2 fois plus pour se battre au Yemen contre les chiites, ils ont autant d'avions que les Danois et les Hollandais additionnés.
On a quand-même un peu l'impression que ça ressemble à une croisade quand on est du côté des sunnites et donc on a fait la bêtise qu'il fallait :
Provocation terroriste --> réaction. Et évidemment maintenant, on est dans un système où...
Qu'est-ce que vous pensez des déclarations de Manuel Valls concernant cette "guerre de civilisation"?
Je pense que c'est une déclaration de d'émoi, il a voulu marquer par un propos à mon avis exagéré, en tout cas qui ne traduit pas la réalité, qu'il y avait quelque chose qui interpellait nos sociétés.
Si en face, c'est perçu comme une croisade?
C'est perçu par eux comme une croisade de toutes façons donc c'est ça qui est important. Parce que, la difficulté du sujet c'est que
quand des occidentaux disent "croisade", ça a une connotation positive, alors que pour les musulmans, ça a une connotation très négative. Puisque c'est l'action impérialiste par nature.
Et quand nous on parle de "Jihad", par nature c'est une intervention agressive alors que pour les musulmans, ça peut être une espèce de discipline personnelle pour s'améliorer.
Et donc les termes ont un double sens, ce qui fait que même si l'on ne parle pas de croisade, c'est pris comme une croisade par eux,
et même si eux ne parlent pas de Jihad, on va le prendre pour le Jihad même quand ça ne l'est pas.
Donc la déclaration de Manuel Valls, elle s'est faite dans l'émoi évidemment d'une décapitation... Mais si on y réfléchit bien,
il y a eu quand même une cinquantaine de morts dans une mosquée chiite au Koweit, 37 mort en Tunisie sur une plage et il y a eu un homme décapité en France.
L'ordre des ennemis pour Daech, c'est pas celui de la France ; c'est les Chiites d'abord, parce que ce sont les musulmans dissidents, ce sont les catégories des mauvais musulmans.
C'est le 3ème attentat sur une mosquée chiite dans la région : 2 en Arabie Saoudite et le 3ème au Koweit. Imaginez une minute qu'on mette une bombe dans une mosquée ici.
Vous voyez le scandale que ça provoquerait. Ca ne choque même pas la communauté musulmane ici, c'est-à-dire qu'il y a une espèce d'empathie
vis-à-vis de ce qu'il se passe là-bas, comme si les chiites étaient des gens méprisables qu'il fallait massacrer.
2ème caractéristique : le tourisme. En Tunisie, c'est-à-dire contre le régime démocratique arabe, on revient dans la logique qu'on évoquait tout à l'heure,
et 3ème épisode seulement : celui de ce type en Isère qui va tenter de faire exploser un site Seveso mais avec beaucoup de bricolages.
Donc le coup de l'acteur solitaire, si vous voulez, c'est à la fois le risque contre lequel il est très difficile de se prémunir puisque ça peut être n'importe-où n'importe quand.
Mais l'avantage de cet inconvénient, c'est que le type ne peut pas monter un système trop compliqué. C'est-à-dire qu'il ne peut pas imaginer de faire un attentat organisé
parce que tous les systèmes de surveillance démontent un réseau. Donc il y a la fragilité de l'avantage si vous voulez.
Vous avez parlé d'un agenda, d'un calendrier de prise de positions par Daech. Israël, dans le calendrier, ça se trouve entre les pays arabes, la France, dans la stratégie de Daech?
Non c'est pas Israël, c'est les juifs. C'est un terme générique. C'est-à-dire que pour eux, c'est la théorie du complot, les juifs sont partout.
Alors par exemple ce qui est très cocasse c'est que quand vous regardez un des principaux ressorts de la conversion que les salafistes arrivent à exercer sur internet,
C'est la thématique et la méthodologie des sectes de l'apocalypse. C'est-à-dire la fin du monde est pour bientôt.
Et donc si vous devenez un bon croyant pendant le court laps de temps qu'il vous reste à vivre, à ce moment-là vous avez des chances d'échapper à l'enfer, etc...
Thématique qu'on avait chez les témoins de Jéhovah, qu'on avait chez Jim Jones, qu'on avait chez d'autres, mais eux, c'est l'annonce de l'apocalypse appuyée sur la réalité historique
puisque la guerre en Syrie, c'était selon eux, ce qu'avait annoncé le prophète. Donc on se retrouve dans un système où dans cette pureté exigée pour
atteindre l'apocalypse [le paradis?] dans les meilleures conditions, il y a l'élimination de tous ce qui vont vous entraver c'est-à-dire c'est une théorie générale du complot,
dans laquelle il y a les mauvais musulmans qui peuvent commencer par la famille, ensuite il y a effectivement tous ceux qui par nature, sont des traîtres à l'Islam, il faut penser que par exemple,
Khaled Kelkal qui était le type qui a été buté dans la région lyonnaise, il était à l'origine des attentats de Saint-Michel, de Luxembourg, en 1993.
Il avait été interviewé par un sociologue allemand 1 an avant. Quand il était un jeune type des Minguettes. Et il disait "le chiisme a été inventé par les juifs pour diviser l'Islam".
C'est-à-dire qu'il arrivait à rendre les juifs responsables du chiisme. Et donc, cette accusation générique contre les juifs c'est "tout juif est par nature mauvais".
D'où l'attitude de Merah avec les enfants de l'école Ozar Hatorah, d'où l'attitude de l'Hyper Cacher, etc...
Et donc c'est pas Israël, puisque Israël c'est trop difficile pour eux, c'est inaccessible, donc il faut prendre les juifs là où ils sont.
Au niveau de la lecture de la stratégie, est-ce que vous pensez que Daech pratique la stratégie de l'anaconda, c'est-à-dire la stratégie de l'encerclement d'Israël, pour ensuite serrer ses anneaux?
Non je ne crois pas, d'abord parce qu'il n'est pas au contact d'Israël, au contraire même, il est au contact de l'armée de Bagdad, de l'armée de Assad,
il est au contraire enfermé dans une guerre religieuse interne à l'Islam. Les massacres aujourd'hui, sont des massacres intra-musulmans.
Quand on regarde les statistiques du terrorisme aujourd'hui, par exemple les bases américaines : le terrorisme tue 10 fois plus de musulmans que de non-musulmans.
Ca veut dire qu'encore une fois, là où l'on pense qu'il y a un acte terroriste dont la logique polotique est de s'opposer à nous, non.
La logique politique de ce terrorisme-là, c'est d'exterminer les mauvais musulmans d'abord.
Et donc les soufis, donc les chiites, donc les mauvais musulmans et donc les malikites, et de détruire tous les signes de cette pratique ignoble.
Quand les salafistes arrivent au Mali, ils commencent par détruire les bibliothèques.
Les bibliothèques malikites, comme l'avaient fait les talibans en d'autres temps, comme l'a fait le GSPC en Algérie.
Donc il y a une espèce de matrice idéologie qui est de même nature que celle de l'Arabie Saoudite, c'est celle qu'elle a diffusé un peu dans toutes ses madrassas.
Et encore une fois, l'ordre des ennemis n'est pas celui qu'on imagine. Donc la question politique c'est "Faut-il intervenir dans une guerre de religion?".
Vous voyez ma question? C'est-à-dire que quand on arrive dans une guerre de religion et qu'à fortiori on n'appartient pas à cette religion, qu'est-ce qu'on est? On est un croisé.
On va revenir sur l'Arabie Saoudite à notre époque. Vos préconisations, si vous aviez les commandes de...
D'abord il y a une préconisation essentielle, c'est qu'on ne peut pas se battre à la place des autres c'est-à-dire on est partit comme ça au moment des décapitations mais sans aucune conditionnalité politique.
C'est-à-dire on va reprocher à Daech ce qui se pratique régulièrement en Arabie Saoudite et ne pas oublier que l'Arabie Saoudite vient de lancer un appel à candidature
parce qu'ils manquent de bourreaux. Ils veulent recruter 8 bourreaux. Donc c'est ce pays-là qu'on va essayer de défendre.
Autre exemple d'actualité, il y a une jeune type qui s'est permis, sur son blog, de dire que la police religieuse avait des pouvoirs excessifs en Arabie Saoudite.
Il a été condamné à 1000 coups de fouet et 10 ans de prison. 1000 coups de fouet ! Il s'appelle Raif Badawi. Je n'ai pas vu de pétition de BHL ou qui que ce soit sur le sujet, peu importe...
1000 coups de fouet... Le type ne fera jamais ses 10 ans de prison, il sera mort avant ! Et je n'ai jamais entendu une quelconque critique contre le système saoudien d'un quelconque homme politique français.
On va donner des leçons à la planète entière, on va expliquer que Poutine est un horrible dictateur et qu'évidemment, Xi Jinping, le chinois, lui aussi a fait des camps de concentration, etc...
Mais jamais on n'a levé le moindre sourcil pour dire aux saoudiens "c'est pas bien". Or, quand on est dans une guerre et qu'on défend ce régime-là, on peut poser quelques conditionnalités politiques.
Est-ce que vous pensez qu'on ne critique pas l'Arabie Saoudite parce que l'Arabie Saoudite est la tête de pont américaine dans la région?
Non je ne crois pas, je crois qu'il y a des logiques françaises et des logiques américaines qui sont un peu différentes vis-à-vis de l'Arabie Saoudite.
La logique américaine est effectivement aujourd'hui quand-même de se libérer le plus possible de la dépendance énergétique saoudienne et ils y réussissent avec le gaz de schiste et le pétrole de schiste.
Les français sont dans une dépendance commerciale très importante à l'égard de l'Arabie Saoudite et on fait taire toutes les critiques avec la perspective de 10 milliards de signature de contrats.
Moi depuis que je travaille sur l'Arabie Saoudite, il y a toujours 10 milliards en instance donc le chiffre ne m'intéresse pas tellement.
Ca se réalise rarement, les 10 milliards d'un coup. Enfin je fais remarquer que dans les contrats en négociation on vend 2 centrales nucléaires EPR à l'Arabie Soudite,
et que visiblement en Iran, dès qu'ils commencent à développer du nucléaire, même de technologie assez classique, on trouve ça très inquiétant.
Dans un pays qui n'a aucun tissu industriel comme l'Arabie Saoudite, qui n'a aucune sociologie de l'ingénieurie de ce genre de sujet, je ne comprends pas la logique.
Qui va entretenir ces centrales et surtout qui va les surveiller? On leur a vendu un laboratoire P4. Un laboratoire P4 c'est un laboratoire extrêmement sécurisé,
dans lesquels en particulier, on travaille contre les armes chimiques et bactériologiques. Je voudrais rencontrer le 1er ingénieur saoudien qui va diriger ce laboratoire P4.
Donc je ne sais pas, je ne comprends pas la logique française. On est engagé dans un système d'alliance où l'on concède à peu près tout ce que demandent les saoudiens,
même si l'on sait que sociologiquement, technologiquement, professionnellement, ils n'ont pas le début du cadre ou du 1er personnel pour garder ce genre de truc. Donc je ne sais pas.
Je vous pose 3 petites questions pour terminer. La 1ère : l'asile à Assange, qu'est-ce que vous en pensez?
Moi je trouve que c'est inadmissible la façon dont on l'a traité et à forciori pour Snowden. C'est-à-dire penser que l'on a interdit un président d'un état indépendant
de survoler le territoire français parce qu'on supposait qu'il était peut-être dans son avion, on a rarement été aussi hypocrite et aussi veule que dans cette décision-là.
Et pour Assange, c'est anadmissible...
Suite aux câbles de la NSA sur les écoutes des présidents?
Oui oui. Et puis pour Assange si vous voulez, il nous rend service en nous montrant que nous sommes écoutés,
que le président est écouté, il l'avait montré à Merkel pour ce qui concerne l'Allemagne, etc...
Qu'on a perdu des marché à cause de ces écoutes?
Oui mais ça on le savait depuis longtemps, simplement il en a apporté la preuve. Disons c'est une voix extérieure.
Quand vous perdez un marché et que vous dites "évidemment les américains ont fait ci, ont fait ça", on vous croit ou on vous croit pas.
Là, personnalité tierce, c'est lui qui apporte la preuve que. Et donc, ça avait cet avantage-là.
Mais encore une fois, on est dans une situation où le type, au moins, on devrait lui accorder l'asile politique, c'est-à-dire qu'il est enfermé aujourd'hui dans l'ambassade d'Equateur,
sans sortir, ça fait 2 ans ou 2.5 ans qu'il est là-bas. Et encore une fois, même s'il doit être jugé en Suède, il est évident que l'Europe doit voter une résolution pour qu"il ne soit pas extradé aux Etats-Unis.
Qu'il soit accusé de quelque-chose par les suédois, je fais confiance à la justice suédoise, mais penser qu'il puisse ensuite être extradé aux Etats-Unis,
bon remarquez, il n'est pas noir donc il ne sera pas buté dans une rue, c'est déjà ça... Donc il est blanc donc il sera jugé et condamné à la prison à perpétuité
puisque vous savez que l'avantage du système américain c'est que l'on peut être condamné à 375 ans de prison, donc même avec réduction de peine, en général on n'en sort pas.
Donc c'est ce qui risque de se passer, c'est ce à quoi a été condamné le jeune soldat qui avait approvisionné Snowden sur les fiches.
Bradley Manning ou maintenant Chelsea Manning.
Bradley Manning ! Sur le fond, l'Europe fait preuve d'une indignité inadmissible sur l'affaire Assange.
2ème petite question : la parole diplomatique européenne et la parole diplomatique française? Elle n'a plus du tout de poids?
Il n'y a pas de parole diplomatique européenne, parce que que regardez, il y a eu 2 scénarios dans lesquels l'Europe s'est totalement divisée.
La 1ère, c'est l'invasion américaine en Irak. Une partie de l'Europe y va, l'autre partie n'y va pas. A l'honneur de la France, la position de Chirac disant "non on n'ira pas, c'est une guerre inadmissible", etc...
Mais vous avez quand-même l'Espagne, l'Italie et l'Angleterre qui y vont. La suite, vous la connaissez, c'est les attentats à Madrid et les attentats en Angleterre.
Donc on devrait réfléchir sur le passé c'est-à-dire qu'encore une fois, quand un pays s'engage dans une guerre à l'extérieur, il peut y avoir dans sa propre communauté musulmane,
des gens qui sont en désaccord et qui donc légitiment leur violence terroriste sur place par le fait que l'on tue des musulmans là-bas.
Exemple qui n'a servi à rien puisque nous, on s'est engagé dans la 2ème version de la guerre en Irak, c'est-à-dire celle contre Daech.
Dans laquelle cette fois, les espagnols et les italiens n'y sont pas allés, vous avez remarqué. Mais pareil, on est dans un système où l'Europe s'est divisé. Donc il n'y a pas de parole européenne.
Les scandinaves ne considèrent pas que leur sécurité se joue en Irak.
Vladimir Poutine?
Et Vladimir Poutine, écoutez, c'est un amateur Poutine à côté du roi d'Arabie Saoudite. C'est vrai, on a raison de lui donner des leçons...
Mais sur le fond, si l'on devait faire un ordre d'abord on commencerait pas foutre George Bush devant la cour pénale internationale,
ensuite en descendant si vous voulez, dans l'ordre hiérarchique, effectivement on pourrait prendre le roi d'Arabie Saoudite ou d'autres...
Donc on est dans ce système extraordinaire, par exemple, j'ai vu récemment sur une dépêche qu'il y a un des princes saoudiens qui va dédier sa fortune
à faire des actions humanitaires, à améliorer la compréhension entre les peuples, etc... Vous allez discuter dialogue des cultures avec les saoudiens vous?
Je ne crois pas même que le mot se traduise en arabe saoudien. C'est-à-dire que vous allez parler tolérance avec ces gens-là? C'est pas possible !
Donc les mecs ont de l'argent et ils sont prêts à raconter n'importe-quoi, en disant "mais on va financer". Donc on est dans un système, c'est formidable, c'est un théâtre d'ombres quoi.
Ils nous disent un truc, on fait semblant d'y croire, on leur répond quelque-chose à quoi ils font semblant de croire.
Mais c'est évident qu'il y a un problème stratégique majeur qui est celui de l'évolution de l'Arabie Saoudite, son comportement diplomatique, sa réforme,
l'ouverture de ses pratiques cultuelles à l'égard des autres musulmans et l'arrêt de l'espèce de... Vous savez, il y a une ONG américaine qui a regardé les manuels d'enseignement saoudiens.
Et notamment dans des écoles qui sont aux Etats-Unis puisqu'ils en ont ouvert certaines.
Et vous trouvez des phrases du genre "un bon musulman ne doit avoir aucune relation avec un mécréant,
non seulement il ne doit pas avoir de relation amicale mais il doit le détester". Je vous la fait brève quoi.
Les anglais ont eu le même constat, ils ont constaté dans des écoles... Blair qui est un espèce de faux-cul assez étonnant,
avait autorisé chacune des communautés à ouvrir ses propres écoles en disant "diversité culturelle". Il y a eu des rapports de l'équivalent de notre inspection de l'éducation nationale,
qui se sont faites sur ces écoles-là où ils ont constaté qu'il y avait séparation des garçons et des filles, que les non-musulmans étaient mis de côté,
et ils présentaient comme voyage scolaire, le pèlerinage à la Mecque, etc...
Et on se dit "mais attendez, on est partit dans quelle direction là?". C'est-à-dire, on ne peut pas faire croire que ces types sont respectables.
Vous savez, Woody Allen définissait la liberté de parole, enfin la liberté dans le droit constitutionnel des démocraties en disant :
"La liberté de parole c'est ne pas donner le même temps de parole à Hitler et à une victime de la Shoah".
Or nous, on est en train de faire comme si ce pays, parce qu'il a de l'argent, était respectable. Il ne l'est pas ! Voila.
Dernière question : un conseil pour les jeunes générations?
Ecoutez, moi j'ai été très agréablement surpris par les gens que j'ai rencontré dans la communauté française musulmane.
Parce que d'abord, cette communauté est en intégration. Contrairement à ce que racontent... Il y a énormément de classes moyennes musulmanes qui sont ingénieurs, techniciens, etc..
Et en particulier, il y a beaucoup de jeunes à qui il faut faire de la place parce qu'il faut leur ratonter les success-story de cette communauté.
Il ne faut pas raconter que les seuls héros de la communauté sont les mecs qui sont partis à Daech.
Mais vous avez des types comme Yazid Sabeg, comme le président du Racing club de Toulon, je veux dire, ils ne sont pas tentés de partir pour Daech.
Donc il y a encore une fois, un rapport avec cette communauté que je trouve aujourd'hui important puisque les attentats terroristes ont modifié l'ambiance.
Et puis encore une fois, c'est un problème interne aux élites musulmanes aujourd'hui, c'est une guerre de religion.
Il faut que les types enseignent la tolérance parce que s'ils ne l'enseignent pas, ils sont en train de se massacrer ente-eux.
Et donc, ce n'est pas la responsabilité des américains comme je l'entends souvent, ce n'est pas la responsabilité des français,
l'examen critique de cette évolution de l'Islam, c'est aux élites musulmanes ou aux français de culture musulmane de la faire.
Il y a des universitaires français qui le font, ces types sont formidables parce qu'ils enseignent un enseignement critique de l'Islam.
Toutes les religions monothéistes ont été intolérantes, 1er principe : il n'y a que mon dieu qui est le bon. C'est la légitimation du massacre des autres.
Donc on ne va pas nous raconter que ceux-là, ils sont plus l'amour et la paix que les autres, non, comme toutes les religions.
Simplement, ils ont un décalage de quelques siècles par rapport à nos propres guerre de religion c'est-à-dire qu"ils les font au XXIème siècle alors que nous, on les a faites au XVIIème.
Mais les conclusions sont les mêmes, en général après un siècle de massacres, on découvre la tolérance.
Pierre Conesa, merci !
Merci.